cool so I've gone ahead and put together
a little bit of a website it may not
look like much because it was made with
Legos but it's actually following the
same principles that we're learning in
this class this green piece in the
background represents the browser window
we can see that the browser here is
actually a little bit wider than the
page I remember a lot of websites like
to Center themselves in the page so they
have content that fits a certain amount
of space and if your browser is wider
than that well there's just a little bit
of space left over and that's okay but
we have a lot of options for the way we
want to lay out our content it can be in
just one long big column like this that
takes up the entire width or it could be
to half columns you know 50 50 or why
not break it into thirds like we have
here or even smaller pieces in this case
it's broken into six we could do a very
popular design where we have one narrow
column and then one wide column or we
could just do some kind of other crazy
design that doesn't really follow any of
these patterns the point being is that
what we want to do is build a grid
system that gives us the flexibility to
make any of the column designs that you
see here let's start thinking about how
to implement responsive design using CSS
in order for a website to resize based
on the size of the browser we're not
going to be able to use a fixed pixel
size to determine the width of columns
instead we'll have to use percentages to
decide how wide our columns should be
once again we're back on the reddit
homepage and let's see if we can make
this column on the right responsive
instead of keeping it at a fixed width
I'm going to go ahead and right click on
it anywhere in here and hit inspect
element to pull up the console AHA and
we can see that the element of the class
side is this sidebar we can see it
highlighted right here let's see if we
can change its width I'll come over here
and scroll down we find a CSS property
called width and currently it's set to
300 pixels remember you can change
websites using dev tools so let's go
ahead and change this one right now
I'll double click and instead of 300
pixels I'm going to set it to 24% and
the reason I'm doing 24% is 300 pixels
is actually
24% of this screens resolution that
you're looking at so 24% keeps this
column at the same size I'll press ENTER
and it looks the same let me get rid of
dev tools so now I'm going to resize a
screen but this column on the right is
actually going to resize responsively
instead of staying at a fixed width this
time when we made the screen smaller we
see that this column got smaller as well
it didn't stay at the same size because
we used a percentage to define its width
it's pretty common to see websites with
grid systems that allow for either two
three or four columns as well as
websites that use one narrow column and
then one wide column which in this case
would take up the other three the
Udacity homepage for example uses four
columns to highlight our featured
courses if you go to our course catalog
you'll notice that we have one narrow
column and then one wide column this one
takes up about a quarter of the screen
while this guy takes up the other 3/4 on
the Coursera homepage you'll see an
example of three columns they've got
their courses laid out in three even
columns which of the following grid
sizes is going to allow for just enough
customization meaning that we'll be able
to get those common two three four
column wide screens and have enough
flexibility to do them however we want
without adding overhead of columns that
we're never going to use do you think
five columns is enough eight columns
twelve columns or do you think that we
need 20 columns to get the customization
we need